you're from the south there's been a lot
of uh disparaging comments about
In-N-Out Burger from people from the
South when they come to La they say
in-n-out's
overrated let's talk fast food for a sec
okay you guys got Zach down there Zach
[__] yeah we love Raising Canes too
that's good I like Raising Canes I get
down on that um I think I think for me
though the the uh uh In-N-Out Burger I
think the burger is is is topnotch I do
love that burger like when I want a
shitty Burger I'm going for that shitty
burger like and that's to me the top
notch fast food Burger yeah I think I
think see that's that's and we can all
agree that the fries are [__] but I
think also too I found out not too long
ago when I got the fries that those are
the only fries on the planet that get
better like two hours after they set out
like they don't they don't get like
shitty like McDonald's fries they
actually kind of get a little bit better
or maybe the and then if you get an
animal style yeah maybe maybe the the
bar is just so low that consecutively 3
hours later just that shitty C like
fresh potatoes they just and then they
here you go they're just they're not
they're not process yeah see maybe
that's what's wrong with them maybe we
just [__] Americans just love just
[__] toxic we do all this processed
[__] that's when I go to Europe too
it's the same way like when I go get
like some fast food like Taco Bell it's
like this [__] not near as good as I
wanted it to be like in like London or
something you know they have Taco Bell
in London yeah oh wow that's an
interesting choice of food if you're in
London well but I I had to go try it out
you know and and but it's different cuz
it's not yeah everything's got to be
real food you know so like even your
McDonald's burger is 100% beef and it's
like I don't want 100% beef I want like
cardboard like crushed up beetles and
[__] I want where's the [__]
cardboard in the crushed up beetles you
know what I'm saying where's a little
fiberglass inside of it you know I don't
want my burger to like you know you've
seen those videos of like a there' be
like a McDonald's burger 5 years later
and it looks the same yeah I want that
inside my body yeah I want I want it to
sit in my belly for the next 12 years
The Eternity I want to be buried that's
the only thing you could take to grave
with you is the McDonald's burgers you
had and your tattoos everything else you
know you can't you can't take you can't
take nothing else when you go but you
can sure take that [__] McDonald's
gut with you there it is man well look
congratulations on all the success lose
control is going
crazy um thank you man we are got to
that at all didn't we it's all right we
got to run it back again yeah got again
congratulations though man it's been
dope to see you know just your whole
I've been following it man so it's good
to it's good to see a a real genuine
person who's just incredibly alien like
talented man I appreciate so much thanks
so much for having me we got y we'll do
it again and again man anytime there it
is man Teddy swims appreciate you
brother boom